ukraine's president has accused russia
of an open act of terrorism after a
missile strike on a city close to the
capital kiev 23 people including three
children were killed in vinicia it's a
city that's far from the front line of
the donbass now the moment that the
missiles hit the central square was
captured as you can see here on a
security camera people are blown off
their feet by the blast wave caused by
those missiles striking the ground and
then
run for cover
wherever they can if you see a dog
running away there for safety
well i'm joined now by uh one of
president zielenski's advisers that ihor
zovka mr zofka thank you very much for
being with us here on sky news and good
morning to you let's just pick up on um
the strike on venezia
can tell us the latest situation in that
city how are people after that missile
attack
well today it is the day of mourning in
this city and in this region uh there
are still many casualties more than 70
people are still in hospitals uh 11
bodies are yet not
yet to be identified including two
children
uh 18 people are missing and the uh
rescue operation is going on at the site
of this uh of these terrible blasts uh
but really i mean it's it's unbelievable
each time it happens in the civilian
city where there were no military people
no military objects this was the central
square of this city with virtual lots of
civilian buildings cultural center and
diagnostic center so nothing to do with
that with equipment built
and each time it's happening in ukraine
and unfortunately it happens practically
if not every day but every week this
severe blast
and
right you are my president when speaking
yesterday at the at the conference in
the hague devoted to bringing russia to
justice to accountability and at the
same time when this conference was
taking place this terrible attack
took place as well so he called this an
act of terrorist and he urged the
countries of the world to recognize
russia as a country sponsoring terrorism
or of course investigations continue to
these kinds of incidents and i presume
that this one will be put forward as
another example of a war crime
yeah yeah i mean
every person who is responsible for this
what is for this blast for the the the
person was pushing the button and we
already know that there was caliber
missiles uh
fired from the uh submarine and the
equatory of the black sea every person
responsible for planning and executing
this operation will be definitely
brought to justice
and how is the fight going here on the
front line in the donbass at the moment
obviously we saw ukrainian troops
falling back from some of those
positions a week or so ago can you tell
us what the latest is in and around the
donbasque and the fight now which is for
luhansk
well the russians are trying to capture
the whole territory of lugansk region
and the coal territory of donetsk region
but they are failing uh they have not
captured all the territory of lugansk
region the major part is really
controlled by them
they are trying to make advances
around some cities in lugansk region and
the nurse region but ukrainian armed
forces
are having a are withstanding those
attacks the problem is that uh russians
are outnumbering ukraine and everything
they're in
men personal in uh equipment and
artillery
sometimes the numbers are very huge so
we barely need the artillery systems
there the mlrs
the armored vehicles as well as the same
we need in the south of ukraine because
the south of ukraine is occupied
and then can be occupied de-occupied
provided that we got enough military
equipment from our partners so each and
every day my president urges the foreign
leaders when he talks
to them or when they come into kiev to
uh
to deliver to ukraine
more more weapon more heavy weapon and
you say that message is is uh put
forward every single day is that message
being received are you getting at this
stage in the war enough support
well if we had enough support we have
already started
the the the counter-offensive liberating
the areas of ukraine which are now
captured by russians no not enough for
today though the dynamics is positive
the number of weapons delivered is
higher than we used to have in the
beginning of this open war
those ramstein meetings three of them
are also positive
some partners
which haven't delivered the weapon
started to deliver this weapon so again
uh the tempo
the speed of this delivery is what
really matters
and i don't want to get into the
strategy too much but there was some
reporting a few days ago about um the
ukrainian armed forces trying to put a
million men
into the battle can you tell us any more
about that and this idea that there may
well be a huge counter attack coming
you know i won't tell you the exact
number first of all i'm not involved in
this i'm not a military responsible
person but i would say that
ukraine has enough manpower to to to to
not only to defend its territory but to
liberate this territory and this is the
task which really is ahead of all the
armpits of ukraine but in order to start
this real operations we need weapon
weapon and weapon
absolutely okay and iho let's talk about
grain then we saw that there were some
moves made in the week
apparently an agreement has been made to
get some of that grain out of the
southern port city of odessa where are
we with that right now
well after that meeting and
you will heard that this media is not
the final one there is a slight
slide very small optimism
so uh the the the the progress is
to be shown uh i think uh there is some
sometime need to to get the final
agreement and that's where the u.n and
secretary secretary general of u.n is
working on
again ukraine offers everything it can
in this situation we offer our brain we
offer our ports several ports can be
offered to start export the grain but
the time is running out uh today is the
middle of july and we still haven't
managed to export major of our
crops from the from the last year but
the next harvesting campaign is already
starting so we will need to
uh have it quickly uh to provide the
countries with our brain to empty our
elevator storages for the new harvest so
time is right now
last one you're on and quickly if you
can what has given you the optimism is
it the fact that there's been a perhaps
a changing position from the russians
what can you tell us
well optimism is given to ukraine by
ukrainians themselves we are ready to
fight and we will definitely liberate
our uh territory and will definitely
have the victory and definitely the
support of international community is
also inspires us